uh yeah like rachel said i'm clinder
hatkimson i'm a senior data scientist
within the office of data services which
is the centralized data science team
here in the city of reykjavik
i used to be an economist still i'm a
chartered economist but i've been
working as a data scientist since 2016
and the data analyst before that
i joined the city of recruit data
science team in march of 2020 which was
you know it was a short welcome because
the second week of my employment
we all got sent home due to covet so
it's been like a
rather
remote back and forth
back and forth between remote and
not just in the office since then but
this data science team is new it was
created
in 2019 the end of 2019
and we're a small team so
there's only six of us
and
although sometimes we do
like data products from start to finish
other times
we are
essentially brought in to help with
projects
in other departments within the city of
reykjavik
but essentially our clients are other
departments within the city
so i'm going to talk to you about
swimming pools and a fun data science
project that has to do with our swimming
pools
so
[Music]
a gig is
[Music]
accounts for a lot of
a large share rather
of iceland's population or about 36
percent
so the population of iceland is 375 000
people but in a given uh there are 135
000 and if you count the like the whole
capital region uh
like the suburbs which are other
like uh other municipalities
they are actually uh like 64
of all icelanders like the capital
region uh
and we're pretty crazy about uh
our swimming pools
uh
so this is gonna be
about a project that is uh
trying to
trying to show people
how crowded each swimming pool is
but
it's also just about how these are hard
in the designs and it's not like
that
you know training the most perfect
machine learning model is hard it's just
like the
project logistics and
what we've come to
call group intercommunication
that's you know that's difficult
sometimes
but
so we have
geothermal
resources
in the form of hot water so
we pump the water from the ground at 80
degrees celsius
so the hot water in iceland is like
incredibly cheap
which is like the
one of the reasons why we have these
pools that they're actually
you know
reasonably uh they're not like this
super fancy thing it's just everybody
goes to a swimming pool and also
throughout the 20th century one of the
five people in iceland was
on average working in fishing so like a
big part of
you know our just our coming of age
story uh as people is going to mandatory
swimming classes through
first to 10th grade
and like yeah i noted that it's roughly
400 hours of mandatory swimming which of
course is like the the worst version of
everything er is the mandatory version
and also uh it's just cold and dark so
we like to get what little sunlight we
can
in the hot tubs
and we also go there to gossip and talk
politics and just socialize
so the idea behind this project is
telling
people
being able to convey to people which
swimming pools are crowded and which
ones are not
so
like since the swimming pools are really
popular
uh
people have been contacting us and
asking if there's any way to see like is
there a website where you can see like
how crowded these are
and welfare workers have also expressed
that interest for clients that are like
success susceptible to sensory overload
so that would be also a cool feature
once we implement this
but like a a big thing was that a
neighboring town hat never it's like all
about municipality competition
they now offer a website dashboard which
shows you how crowded their two swimming
pools are
but in their case they have staff
manually count the patrons
as far as i'm aware
but also during covet
swimming pool availability was cut to 50
of normal capacity for certain periods
so when that
became clear
we
realized okay this is something that we
have to do not just
you know to
it wasn't like it went from being uh
like a nice to have to something that we
wanted to work on
so
this is something that comes from the
department of sports and leisure within
the city of reykjavik and this is their
pitch but it's not a direct quote
so they say okay so we've updated the
gates or the turnstiles at our swimming
pools to modern electronic turnstiles
with these modern gates we can now get
information on how many people are at
each swimming pool through an api on
application programming interface
and their question is can you help us
present this data
uh showing how crowded each pool is
so this is essentially at that point
this is just like um
honestly just like we figure it's a
simple shiny app and
just a question of
database how are we going to present
this if like if we can just access
the data that tells us the number of
current visitors for each pool
so
like i said this is a project that is
spearheaded by the department of
sporting leisure they come to the like
the centralized data science team to ask
for our help
but with regards to getting the data
this is of course a little bit more
complex
because
department of sports and leisure has to
deal with
the icelandic partner to the
manufacturer of the gates
and
they are our contact
your contact partner for the actual
vendor the gate manufacturer
uh
and this is this is my train of thoughts
but still it should be pretty
straightforward once we get the data
right and the clown face there is put
for emphasis
so at the start of the project i
envision this as a rather simple project
we read the data from the api using the
httr package
of course we're going to be doing some
data cleaning using the tie diversion
pair
so we'll visualize with gt plot
make that visualization interactive with
ggraf probably
and then make that into a reactive shiny
app and deploy it to either shinyapps.io
or rstudioconnect
and this of course is a tragic
miscalculation on my part because
i'm
assuming that okay
the data might take some time because of
this
you know communication and
they are not like
yeah
it's it's hard to
like make
another team
in
like a company twice removed from you
care about
your product as much as you do
essentially so they are not going to be
with like the internal fire that we have
uh for this project at the
at the data science team
so with the five uh five item list
i'm assuming a lot of things about the
data and the api
and just before we get into the like the
nitty-gritty of it
like simple things like
these projects can be time-consuming
because there are like difficult things
or complex things but also the simple
things
uh
necessarily aren't necessarily simple
because
different groups have different
priorities we have other priorities
during the during working on this
the biggest
was
the cobit dashboard that we
needed to put up and maintain
at the same time that we were like
starting work on this
and then there's a group into
communication
and
like
forced communication protocols is
is
kind of
maybe
bad
a badgers words but essentially it's
like we need to talk to the icelandic
partner and they talk to the vendor
because essentially
like the icelandic partners
is the company that we buy the solution
from
and then there's uh lawyer stuff one
when lawyers between uh maybe the city
of reykjavik and the vendor start
talking you can you know things just to
slow down
so this is a timeline
uh and it's absolutely horrible if you
look at it so
the
like the first idea to like
we should maybe do this uh do this thing
uh is in february of 2020 and
there's like
this request for data sent out hey can
we
access this api
and you know lots of image back and
forth and let me show you the emails
so
like
it's maybe
just 20 emails from one
like thread of emails that i
had up but it's not accounting for like
meetings and stuff like that
but then you
take you take into account like that
between march and june
we like we did not have our
eyes on this particular ball because we
were focusing on focusing on
putting up the covet dashboard and
maintaining that
and keeping that correct
but
during the summer we start to push for
more like what about this data we asked
you know you said this can you maybe
look into that and in september uh we
come to the conclusion like okay you can
get this data and here's how you
here's how it would happen but
according you know according to our
lawyers
uh
according to our lawyers you'd have to
pay a fee to access this api and then
the lawyers from sports and lisa say no
no according to our interpretation of
this contract we don't actually have to
pay this fee you're talking about
so that it get there
yeah gets in the way but after christmas
uh things start rolling and we get the
get the data
but then we actually get the data and
this is
this is friday last friday
and if you look at
look at this chart you can see that for
five of the six
swimming pools in question these are
like
strictly increasing
these aren't showing us like how many
visitors are at each swimming pool
and it comes down to the fact that
for five of these six pulls like the
hardware isn't able to count out it only
counts in
but for the sixth
slow which you see there in the left
bottom corner
it also looks kind of weird and we'll
get into that in a bit but essentially
you can see that it's not strictly
increasing
so it turns out
like i said the gate hardware for these
five pools
can only come visitors into the pool so
current visitors isn't current visitors
it's the cumulative sum of total
visitors
up to that point during the day were
like
at the point of time
uh where we sent the get requests
through to the api
okay
there's more
if you look at loaders like
you
like this looks rather normal
at like
it passes the first eyeball test like
okay this this looks like actual data
but it's actually super weird if you
look at like the end of the day there
are no people leaving the swimming pool
uh
like at the end of the day
so when the pool closes and half an hour
after the pool closes there are still
around 175 people
in the swimming pool according to the
counter and we'll
get to that a bit later
but
essentially from this api
we don't know when the people leave we
know when people
come into the swim pool provided we are
querying the api
so we ask ourselves what if we model the
duration of
each visitors stay
or rather it's five minute intervals
uh like for all the visitors in each
five minute interval
because we're running uh
the get request to the api every five
minutes
and that way we can
essentially get
if we
put five-minute
intervals between the get request we can
say okay here are between 6 30 and 6 35
there were 20 people
that
entered
our pool
if we just know
how long on average these people would
stay in the pool before leaving we could
essentially
put together a data set this
says okay here's an approximation of how
many people are at our dialogue at the
moment
the big idea is
that we request historical data through
the icelandic vendor
and i
like i said uh
but maybe it wasn't clear so i'll
reiterate learners like uh has in and
out data
well it's not perfect it's just that the
other five
swimming pools only have in data
and if two assumptions hold that
people's stays
are not inherently different in duration
between leurtersler and the other pools
and the second assumption that people's
days are not inherently different
integration between people who are
counted out and people who are not
counted out of leother's leg which
we figured out
is essentially the problem
so
like the real kicker is that some people
are counted out of letters but not of
but if these assumptions hold and we get
the historical data we figure we can
train a model on historical loaders like
stator state durations
of the people that are actually counted
out
and then predict durations onto the live
api data for the other five proofs
and that's what we did and this is uh
essentially
like the sketchup of
how we did that
so within
our studio connect we have an r marked
on document
that is scheduled to run every five
minutes
it gets the
it gets the data from the live api
and
it also gets data from a pin we use the
pins package
uh
it reads in
the in data that has essentially been
read before okay
this is a terrible way to explain it
sorry okay so essentially every five
minutes we read the live data but also
every five minutes we check
uh for other like the historical
uh
not
not the historical data that we were
hoping to get from the
vendor but like every other api call
we've saved that to a pin
that we pinned to the rstudio connect
board and then we
join those together so
we can then rewrite
over the pin
and
we then create a shiny app which read
reads like let's
say for today
if the shiny app were to look at this in
data it would have an account of all uh
like
all the
like
point in time counts for
every every pool
and
the shiny app then takes
up another pinned object
which is a
linear model
and then predicts when these people
would leave so you can present within
the shiny app
an estimate of how many people are there
and just to go into the
like
what we essentially did we started just
on a local machine
and once we've got uh access to
historical data from
the vendor you would say save on google
cloud
we read that data from bigquery
using the big r query packets but now
we've used no usdr studio professional
drivers and the dpi package
we fit beginner model for the
predicting the duration
and the predictors are is it a weekend
how
like how long since the
summer solstice or how long until the
summer solstice
and then we have a natural spline term
of hours
and we
use
a
seven knot
for the spline term
and it's
we toyed around with it but essentially
we based the
like the number of not
on just staff knowledge so it's
we're saying it's
different
the duration
is influenced by of course what time of
day it is
and
we've
fit the knots for the spline at these
points in time because they say okay
it's different between
6 30 and 9. so put a knot
between put a knot at 6 30 and another
not at nine
and then they say but also during the
during lunch hours people stay like a
much shorter time because these are
people that have maybe
45 minutes
or an hour for lunch if they're very
lucky and they run to the swimming pool
to you know
get a swimming
and these people stay for a short time
so the essentially
the
it's appropriate to fit uh not
uh around the
uh
lunchtime and so on so it's this is not
something that we
like
were
we didn't have like
some
fitting where it was
you know decided by an algorithm we just
talked to people does this make sense
and then we have evaluated different
combinations
of knots on the training set
so like i said the armageddon document
is scheduled
to read data from the api key that data
and wrangle it into a table also read
data from the in data set pin
and then append the cleaned api data
table to the in data set and then pin
that updated in data set to the rstudio
board which is what i was trying to show
here
so
we have then a shiny application that
just reads the
in
data set pin
reads the model pin which we have
deployed to
our studio connect from our we trained
it on our local machine but we deploy it
to our studio connect
and then we run a predict function for
that to create an estimate of current
visitors
so this is
an example of that this is data from
september
and
this is
rather reasonable
uh
for the five pulls that we are focusing
on
but
learn the flag
is
still not good and
we
essentially we try to do some things
which i'm not going to go into here we
tried another
linear model to correct
it didn't work out and the way we found
out that it didn't work out was we
essentially
gave this ad to the managers of the swim
pools to evaluate and they said
these five pools they're they're okay
they're actually like
they were really happy with it but load
them slow it wasn't even close
so that's something we have to
we still have to figure out
but
like
why is this a cool thing because in my
opinion it's super cool because it's all
r and r studio connect
so
like we're in our shop here at the data
science team
and if it's all our we can move at our
own pace
and for this part of the project there
were no outside constraints
or you know inefficiencies in how we
communicate with other groups
and we also get to run into the problems
ourselves
and then we know what to take into
account if parts of the process are
outsourced beyond the team
and we've actually had this like
a way to explain it is to think about uh
like building a car and
i've told rachel this before
essentially we're thinking about uh
if we
are trying to build a car there are many
components that need to be built
and essentially we are saying we can put
up a fast prototype and do everything
ourselves
uh and that way we there's there's no
chance of us
running into a problem if we outsource
to another team let's say
you take this part of the project let's
say in the example of a car
you create the like the seats for the
car
and then we get that back and we realize
okay this didn't fit they need to talk
to us but if we just do this ourselves
we run into that problem ourselves and
when we've built like a
a rather
you know
crummy version of the car
uh
as like a
like a minimum viable product we can
then say okay we need to outsource this
thing
we need to follow protocols regard with
regards to reading the api
and then we outsource that to our it
team
but then we can say here's what we ran
into and here's what you need to take
into account and that way we get results
so much faster
so this is our current
setup
so
we are
not actually reading from the api
using our rstudio connect now it's put
into web methods where which is an
integration platform which our it team
uses
so that's uh
it's just uh
protocol and it's
it's just like super convenient for us
because it gets written to
our azure data lake storage
and
or rather the in data
that is
created every five minutes
that gets written to azure data lake and
we can then read that in our our
markdown document every five minutes and
then we do a prediction
based on the linear model which is still
just a pin on rstudio connect because
there's like no need to complicate that
and then we have a prediction table
which is what the shiny app reads
uh on like when you fire up the shiny
app you're just reading from one
one table which is the uh
like the prediction table which is a pin
on our studio connect uh a board on our
studio connect
but just before we finish up
uh i want to talk about the other flag
because that's like a that's a super
interesting problem
uh
and like i said here the data for
lettuce leg is absolutely whack
and uh
like you see it's a technical term and
that has everything to do with how nice
the staff at the flag are so like i said
it's the only
it's the only pool that
comes in and out
but
when there are say school kids who go to
their mandatory swimming
uh like let's say there's a row or a
queue of
40 school kids trying to leave the
swimming pool after the swimming classes
the
the
staff at lourdes layer is not going to
require everybody to
take their like their arm band
or bracelet rather and put it into the
machine which then counts it okay this
individual came in you know 90 minutes
earlier they're leaving now they just
opened the like open the gates and the
kids throw these bracelets into a
like little bucket by the
by the entrance essentially and it also
has to do with like late at night when
there's a lot to do they don't make
people actually
wait for
you know
wait their
time
in the queue
so it's all due to kindness and i you
can read that phrase damn you kindness
you ruined my dad and the voice of the
british community comedian richard a
caster
you can
you can do that to yourselves
but uh
so the things we're trying uh
of course the first thing we wanted to
do was just ask the vendor to make
changes to the api to separate the in
data from the output data for lertosler
we're still waiting on this
but in the meantime
we have you know
because we really want to do it we
really want to get this thing out we've
been working on it for a long time
so uh one idea was to use a secondary uh
like
another counter that is located by the
actual pools in lotuslove not by the
entrance
but this has proven unfruitful because
it's just a traffic counter it doesn't
say that people are going in this
direction or in this direction so it's
just
we can't tell you how many people are
going into the pool and how many people
are going out of the pool
and then
this is like
a part pardon my english or rather part
of my friends for what i'm about to say
but this
like the next thing feels like something
you agreed on the twit twitter account
internet of [ __ ] which is like an
internet of things like
where it roasts these
smart solutions
but there are smart lockers in lauter's
leg but like the internet of [ __ ] part
is where it's unclear the firmware can
be updated to the most recent version to
support live data so uh for
time being we only have historical data
for the smart lockers which i believe
gets read into a database
every night when the pools are closed
so this uh
so
essentially we tried a couple of things
they didn't work we're waiting on the
vendor to make changes to the api and
i'm sure it's
it's going to be
you know
oh let our lawyers talk to your lawyers
about this key it'll end up some
anticipated terribly sorry
but also before i end like this here was
a gross oversimplification
where we're only talking to
uh like the icelandic partner to the
vendor
uh there are also gyms that uh
have access to the pools so there
so you can go to a gym that's like
located next to a pool
and they have separate counters into the
pool so after you've done your workout
at the gym you can actually walk through
some tunnels into the pool area
and
we have
yet to
figure out how to count those because
that's we deal with department of sports
and leisure
and department of sports and leisure
deals with the owners of the gym and the
owners of a gym uh talked to some
icelandic partner to a vendor which
talked to
uh you know an international renter so
it's like a more complex
like
pipeline essentially pipeline of
information
so still to do
uh we need to account for like gym
patterns that use the swimming pools at
lower slug and perezler
and
like
the final point of this presentation is
of course there's going to be something
else but we don't know it yet
so i'd love to take questions on this
i'm sure i
yeah we have 20 minutes and i'm sure
there are some things that i did not
explain properly so i'm all ears
thank you so much leonard that was
awesome and i'm just thinking it's lunch
time here it would be so cool to be able
to just go to a pool right now
um so there's a lot of great questions
that came in on slido
um and so
just so everyone knows and josiah can
help me share the link again um you can
ask questions there if you want to put
your name in i could also call on you to
like add additional contacts too
but i'll start with some of the
anonymous ones
and one was and quite a few people
commented that they really liked that
first visualization you shared um and
they said could you kindly share the r
syntax of the first visualization that
showed your email tracking
the day we requested the day we received
okay yes so this is
this presentation is like uh
an armored presentation so
the timeline
it's
essentially
three
gt plot graphs and i can share this uh
i should have added my github account
but i'll share this like this is
this oh like oh i'm sorry i'm not
sharing the screen i'm sharing that
i'm sharing the chrome browser i can see
the presentation screen okay
okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna
share the
secondary screen
so i can
like
where's the share screen
okay hopefully
and i can share your
do with the recording
oh now i can see the code okay
okay so this is like this is just the
data and it's a
like this is the first gg plot and it's
not just a mess
but i didn't think i'd be sharing this
code but i'd be happy to like
data realism
so yeah i'll put that on my github and
rachel you can
share that perfect awesome
thank you
someone else asks is there a live link
to the swimming pool dashboard currently
uh not that is accessible outside like
the city of reykjavik team because we
haven't because of our problems with
loaders
currently there are two apps
one app is for
the
managers of the swimming pools and the
other one is like the in progress
because i hand
like i make the
the plane looking shinier but then we
have
the
thor who's a data scientist a great data
scientist there at the city of red creek
who has like this artistic guy and he
makes
like all the pretty production shiny up
so that one
is hopefully you know soon to be
released but at the moment uh no it's
not accessible
thank you
and also if people have questions you
want to ask live as well i'm just going
to
allow people to unmute themselves too
and if you want to raise your hand
you can jump into
but i will
go to the next anonymous question unless
anyone has one you want to ask live
okay
one is did this project initiate any
improvements in user tracking
or is everybody just content with the
way you patched the problem and things
will stay the same i think you maybe
mentioned at the end about the api
possibly
changing
yeah but uh an another thing is that
like there have been
like
discussions between
sports and leisure and the managers of
the actual swimming pools with regards
to change
like it's perfectly acceptable for
further 40 school children to not be
counted out
but
like for the later like if there's two
full-grown adults waiting in queue like
you can they're essentially saying
you know we'd appreciate if you stop the
kindness just a little bit and you know
let these people be counted out so
that's
something that we haven't seen in the
data yet but
provided that
it provided that
we fix things
with
like once we get the gym data and then
we can say like
can we look at this if if they were to
like
be more
or rather less kind let's just say less
kind now they count people up
thank you
i love when you talk about like the
people behind the data and thinking
about like who those actual individuals
are and what they're doing
as they go about their day
yeah
another upvoted question was could you
compare your use of plotly
and g giraffe in my person am i
pronouncing that package correctly um
did you use both or prefer one over the
other
i actually i started out using ploty
because i've been using that for a long
time
but then
thor who's
this
you know artistic data scientist that i
mentioned earlier
he
pointed me in the direction of ggraf and
i'd much i much prefer that now it's
because like you just created a gt plot
and then you wrap it in the ggraf
and it's it's instantly
comes
like an interactive visualization
provided you change the like the geom
part so it says it's
i like the gt plot
like flow to things and this is like a
perfect extension to that
cool thank you
i'd love to hear
from other people too so you don't have
to just keep hearing my voice
if you want to ask questions live
um i see
uh gregory or gregoire you have a
question yes
can you hear me well yes i can yeah okay
thank you leonard for the representation
actually i'm an economist too so that's
that's nice to know that i'm not the
only one interested in data science
and i wanted to know how much
the city or the public entity is
interested in
[Music]
all what you can
provide as that analyst or economy store
i mean
are there many projects are willing to
put you in or it's like still
growing as you mentioned because it's
it's new to them
awesome question thank you uh
it's
it's actually just like skyrocketing
so like i said the data team is
relatively new
at like
years end 2019 but uh
but now like
uh
at the beginning there were we didn't
have these like
fixed protocols in place how we did
these
uh projects but now just with a little
experience we've been like moved into
the i t
i t departments framework for
like
this is the way we accept projects and
this is how we allocate time to them
and like
since that it's
uh it's become like
it's been made clear to
uh the departments within the city of
reykjavik like here's a team of data
scientists if you have a an interesting
use case or something urgent which
you want them to do here's
how you would go about getting them in
and it's like people are super
interested in
uh doing that and it has to do with like
you do you do one
cool thing for
like uh
the department of schools
and the next and after that they're like
okay we like
they of course know like the potential
but
then when when you hand something off to
them they say okay this is something
that's
like
this is something that it's now
available it's like real essentially so
yeah like super
super interesting
all things data currently
okay very cool very cool
thank you very much
thank you
thank you um jaiwan i see you asked a
question on slido and and put your name
there can i pass the mic over to you to
add some context there
yeah sure
um just wanted to know how the teamwork
or delegation works within your team do
you face any limitations because you're
in the public space uh yeah just
wondering how the teamwork delegation
works
uh
yeah okay great question like like i
said we're there's only six of us so
we have our like
chief data officer inca
and she's like the head of the operation
but we have a data engineer
and we have me a data scientist and my
my skill set is mostly geared towards
predictive modeling but also you know
analytics you know reports something
that needs to be done
and then we have sorbet whose
he's
like a super
machine learning engineer
type of data scientist he's like
so competent at that but he's also like
this
he's our go-to guy
to like finalize the
you know shiny apps and do
like
these more complex data visualizations
map stuff and things like that
and then we have
siri who's also a death scientist and
she is
she is
like doing
more of the report
things
currently
as our like our junior scientist
uh
and then we have creamer who's also a
data engineer so we have essentially
three
data scientists two engineers and the
chief data officer and
the tasks that
palla
and grimmer the data engineers they are
split
more along the lines of like
which
departments the data comes from
it's a rather complex conversation but
uh like
the
between the science data scientists
it's more like
focused on like what we're good at like
serious uh really good at
not just you know shiny applications
that are like doing reports but
like other things like power bi and
click sense and stuff like that so
thank you
and i
say face you have your hand raised as
well
can i pass it over to you
uh thank you rachel um
for giving me the chance
um and my apologies if i
i might have missed this um
right in the beginning
what i'm wondering is it's quite an
interesting project
but the thing that i'm curious about is
that what was the
uh
what's the problem that you're trying to
solve with this project and what was the
business case for this if there is a
strong business case for it
yeah
so i didn't show the
yeah
did i show this
slide i'm not sure if i should if i
showed this
slide so uh
it's it's it's it's essentially like the
first the
the first
thing that like sparked this idea was
just citizens
trying to figure out which
pools were crowded and sending you know
calling it to the city offices is there
a way to show
us which can i you know can i
tell if leotisla is super crowded right
now
and it's just this interest which
started the conversation but then once
we you know that idea is part
uh i've also talked to welfare workers
within the city of reykjavik and they
are like
essentially because
if they have clients that have
like
are susceptible to sensory overload they
usually go to like really remote
uh swimming pools like in the out of the
suburbs like clear bergstrom which is
not one of the pools in questions here
but essentially just just to make sure
that they're at the non-crowded pool
and then uh
like covet came and that's when
the project actually
uh
you know became an actual project
although we like we don't have 50 cap
capacity now it was only for like uh
two one month periods
but that's when there were actually like
lines outside the swimming pools and the
idea was if we can get this you know up
and running fast enough we can then show
people okay this
this pool is currently too crowded for
you to go there but here's a pool that
is actually like not crowded but sadly
not sadly like it's great that we don't
have these
uh limitations anymore but like we we
didn't manage to do it within that you
know
two months period yes so i guess going
forward and now that that explains a lot
actually thank you i think i've seen
something similar
in terms of uh people trying to check uh
how the crowded the supermarkets are
so yeah yeah going forward if you could
probably link it with the booking system
for the swimming pool then you might end
up with a
really nice uh
business backing for that so no it's a
great project thank you
thank you so much and like that's
that's like uh
a five year five year plan but it's i
think well you already have everything
you know
so
yeah yeah
but like the booking system is is
connected
to the so you can actually
if we were to you know team up with it
we could actually
join forces and within this app you
could not only see which pools are like
which pools are crowded and not crowded
you could actually like buy a ticket
so yeah awesome
thank you
thank you hey oli has uh his hand is
raised as well and then i'll go over to
some of the other anonymous questions
hey oli
hi leonard what is it
hello
guys again and
i'd like to add also that the city of
reykjavik is on this digital
transformation journey
and
so the requirements are also coming
straight from the business so that we
have these digital leaders scattered
around
the business
and they know their stuff and they come
come to the data team and the department
of innovation and services with projects
that they have prioritized based on
you know their operational needs
but you know i'm here for question now
and
we are really close friends
uh since you guys
like everybody knows everybody here
they're like five or five of us here in
iceland
so i should add that only is our former
uh chief data officer which you know
created this team of avengers as i saw
someone call it in the chat
and you you certainly are but uh you you
um
i'm allowed one difficult question but
uh i'm not good
but i want to
answer it
i i'm i want to have a discussion on
like i think this is super interesting
for the people joining this call is
so
so we're building this prediction model
for for predicting how many people are
visiting the pools
um
what's the level of accuracy that is
needed for that in terms of
like
value for the business for the for the
proof business
so
could you could you enlighten us on that
because we have we've had
so often but i'm gonna
because i feel that it's super important
for data science projects
are you is it valuable to predict
whether there are 50 visitors or 51 it
is like is there a
difference does this change something
for me but isn't the value like
predicting whether 50 or 500
and
yeah
it's for talking about prediction
accuracy in terms of value
take it away
thank you holy so
the thing we did like we
we evaluated these models on training
data but we don't have test data because
we're not going to ask the
staff there to you know count every five
minutes and create a test data set for
us but rather what we did was
[Music]
leave it up to the managers and the
staff of the swimming pools
to
look at the app
and
essentially
they would be like the gauge if this is
accurate enough for them and the thing
is they like
one case where
they were doing like these daily spot
checks okay it's 2 p.m
you walk around the swimming pool and
tell me how many people there are and we
can then compare that to the
to this app that this data science team
has given us
and what they found out was like it was
like in
like well within their
like margin of reasonable accuracy
because it like
only alluded to it doesn't matter if
there are 70 or 75 people at the
swimming pool but it does matter if it's
75 or 200 people
so like one example was like we did the
spot check it was 72 but the model uh
showed 76
we're completely fine with that
and you know so that essentially like
and this is what made it fun because as
only knows at my last place of
employment i was
like always
you know doing these
increasingly complex uh machine learning
algorithms
just to get like you know
0.07 percent accuracy increases and
that's like that's not the fun stuff
but like the fun stuff is you know doing
a project
uh like a complete project and saying
okay here's like
this uh
here's our estimate and
we're not trying to you know was it
squeeze blood out of a stone i'm not
sure if that's even an english
expression it is an icelandic
so uh
so it's
yeah it's fun it's all i'm gonna say
like working on a project that it's it
doesn't matter if it's 72 or 76 it's
just well within the margin
it's all about bringing the like correct
level of accuracy for value the value
for the business like you mentioned in
the in the talk and i really like that
this
like we evaluate our models through
discussions with
with our stakeholders and i thought that
was good
and it was an awesome presentation
cleaner thank you you are awesome thank
you
you're awesome ollie good to see you
again
thank you so much
um so a few other anonymous questions um
in here if it's okay if we go over a
little bit
do you have to run with me finally
awesome and then for anybody who missed
it i'll share the recording as well so
they can uh get their answers too
but one was what was it hard to set up
the
azure or aws whichever cloud
provider you used with rstudio connect
and scale it up for production
so like
if it's regards to setting up our studio
connect on azure
that's like that's beyond my
comprehension that's something that the
data engineers did but getting our
studio connect to talk to
our azure data lake
like storage container is super easy and
it's it's the same for just you know
doing it on your
essentially local machine
so that's been something that's been
kind of a surprise
in that i can i can use the pins packets
so i i can set up a pin board on rc
rstudio connect and i can set up another
pin board on
azure data link
so i can then use like the same pin
underscore get function to get data from
the
data lake and data from our studio
connect but the way we even
eventually ended up doing it was using a
package called assure store
from
microsoft employees an open source
package just on cran
and that's essentially how we read the
data currently into
into our studio connect just
you know there's a couple of
it's like
it's not a one-liner but like the pin
gap
but maybe
three or four lines of code so it's been
really really nice
and and sorry and the key to that is
like
uh setting the environment variables in
our studio connect
so you don't store any like credentials
in your code
thank you leonard
um a few
all right let's see there's quite a few
other questions still here what package
do you use for the model
so this is like a super simple uh like
linear splines model so essentially the
only packages we use use for the
modeling are just you know
if you till
oh it probably starts that has the lm
function and then uh the splines package
which has the natural splines function
but then we used uh yardstick from titan
models to just
uh do the evaluations
of uh
of accuracy on the training data
awesome thank you
um is there a way to manually remove the
in data
for wow and someone's going to make me
pronounce this pool larger slurg
sorry is there a way to is there a way
to manually remove the in data
um if anyone i know is anonymous but if
anyone wants to add any other context
feel free to jump into
so it's like i i think i understand the
question and the problem is that we we
can't do it because
what we see is like the difference uh
between five-minute
intervals so uh essentially if
if minus two people are recorded as the
change
between let's say 630 and 635 we we have
no idea looking at the data to tell if
that minus two is because you know
nobody
entered the pool but two people left
or if like 10 people entered the pool
and 12 people left so sadly
the data doesn't allow us to do that
thank you
um could you let us know what other data
science projects you currently are
working on or have planned other than
the swimming pool and cova dashboard
so one of the things is
estimating like the need
for personnel at our call center
that's something that's uh
that we're working on
although it's not a priority priority
currently but uh
there are like in-depth reports
regarding uh just uh
not like a covet dashboard but you know
the
economic uh variables
regarding you know the effect of kovit
we have that
it's both a report and we've done uh
like a dashboard for that
but essentially like uh
like this
40 page hour mark down document that we
update
and then hand into
like
city hall essentially and there are
we did this deep dive into uh
like
the costs of uh
essentially just um
i don't know what the english term for
this but essentially like
if
if there are any special needs
in you know school districts
and it was essentially a deep dive into
looking if there were
unintended
essentially biases if if some
groups of students were
being
getting
more
financing of special needs than others
and stuff like that so
it's
it's all kinds of things
awesome thank you
um a
great question here for others on the
call who maybe are going through the
very beginning stages of of this process
how did you get administration to buy
into our studio connect
and how did you get around data
protection issues
so
like this has
a lot to do with ole we saw earlier
he's now like
a suit and tie type of guy running
things
and you know as a manager but i think
like the
key thing is that he's like
a phd in statistics and has been
using r since 2006. so he understood
the importance of allowing
people with specialized skill sets to
like use the tools that
are most suited for them
so he wasn't going to say okay but
here's
this other solution that you know we can
save a couple of bucks on but you know
you'll be out of your element and i
think it's just
not every place is going to have
like
somebody that moved
moved upwards from being a data
scientist into the management role and
then can influence decisions like that
but
i think
i think it has to a lot to do with just
communicating
like
you hired us because we have
these particular skill sets
uh and
we're not like
it's like this thing where
you know somebody
somebody is an r programmer but then
they come to this new place and they say
oh
like can't you do this in python and
then they have to like
become this sub power python program
instead of using their super power of
you know having worked in our
for like the last 10 years or whatever
i
um
i just remembered i forgot to make an
announcement earlier and i apologize for
that to the lander analytics team but i
did want to let everyone know that
there's also an r in government uh
conference coming up soon so i wanted to
say that before a few other people have
to to run
and they're the lander analytics team is
actually
so kind to provide us a 20
promo code for anybody who attended the
meetup
so i'm going to share that on the meetup
page as well
but the conference is on december 9th
and 10th
so i'll i'll share the link in the chat
window too if anyone wants to check it
out but it seems like it would align
very well with
the meetup today and and
for a bunch of people who are in the
government space but
if anyone from lander analytics is on
and you want to jump in and provide any
more info feel free to to do so too
and my bad for not saying that earlier
i'll share the link in in just a second
um
there's two other questions
left and
i know you touched upon this one a
little bit but
it was for this project what profiles
were involved into constructing all this
um not only the data science team but
stakeholders and technical team
okay yeah so
the profiles meaning
i'm sorry
i think i think um
they mean so like or i'm i'm assuming so
feel free to jump in and i know it was
anonymous but
thinking about this
um project specifically and
getting that from
from zero to into production
who were the stakeholders that you had
to work with and who were the technical
teams that you had to work with to get
that done as well okay okay
awesome thank you
i'm showing you what a mess no i'm not
sharing the screen okay thankfully
so uh
the
the two big ones were uh like uh
at the department of sports and leisure
there are
like
there are it's like a like a mini i.t
department
and
we
essentially report to them but they also
help us with communicating to
you know vendors and partners of vendors
but then uh within the department of i.t
we also had to
we needed to
move the api requests to the like the
centralized
integration platform so there is a
special uh it's called web methods this
integration platform so we had to uh
essentially deal with them
but the the they are
perhaps not
perhaps not stakeholders essentially but
like
comrades
but
i think like
the two largest stakeholders are
essentially the i this like mini i.t
team
at the department of sports and leisure
and the managers of the swim push
because there's a
manager of each swim because these are
like rather large establishments
and
because essentially we're hoping to
make their lives
somewhat easier also the staff at the
swimming pools because
like
provided this goes as planned and people
actually start to look where it's
crowded you know it's hopefully going to
be more distributed
across all the poos
i'm not sure if that answered anything
really but
it was my attempt at that
i thought it was helpful to me but feel
free to unmute yourself if you have any
follow-up questions on that too
one of these days we'll all be in person
and we'll feel more comfortable all like
talking as a
group maybe at a
our studio conference one day we'll have
these
birds of a feather groups again
um the other question is how did you
communicate the need for staff hours for
future projects
um
so for example with only six people
right now and this interest and data
projects growing
um
will you need to kind of advocate for
for more data scientists
this is like uh this is kind of you know
the secret sauce of this project
is that it
because it was agreed to before like the
workflow was finalized with regards to
allocating you know the resources of the
data scientists
uh this has been kind of you know it's
been
it it wasn't put in a box
essentially it wasn't there wasn't some
uh these are the man hours that are
allowed to and it and it's not like but
of course that that's also part of the
shortcomings of this project because if
it had been
uh
you know put in a box and just scoped as
a project like we do now now that we've
moved into that phase of our operation
it we probably would have like
ran into these
like speed maps much earlier
instead of
just you know accepting the project as
is
and diving into it and then it kind of
becoming a side project because you know
because it is a rather weird project
i'll jump onto it when i have nothing
else to do and you know
when
when there's like oh you can get this
data you can get this connection
like from the gyms and stuff like that i
can you know
i can kind of treat that as a
side project with
sorry with less oversight than uh like
the regular project
but
at the same time we like if we had
put this into the formalized process and
scoped it i'm sure we would have
like because now it's been like okay
here's the problem we ran into let's
talk to the department of sport and
leisure and they'll go oh why don't you
use like the secondary counter let's try
that and we go oh we didn't know there
was a secondary counter nobody had told
us that and when that doesn't work like
oh why don't you why don't you try the
like the smart uh you know locks
in the in lotus lane like oh nobody
nobody told us that they were smart
locks so it's been like a blessing and
the curse that this has been kind of
like
a rather unofficial project so to speak
thank you leonard and just you
mentioning that like these side projects
was making me think about something
which i think is really cool that your
team does on fridays where you have like
the chance to work on
like anything that you want to and was
curious if you could just tell us all a
little bit more about that too
like i'm the least like you'll get the
least interesting answer out of me
because you know
it's going to be this project so but uh
like uh just
name uh so thor
our data scientist he's uh he's he's
been like focusing on
uh getting up to speed with d3
and you know
taking graphs that are you know based on
data and r
and then putting that into like a
javascript
to create a d3 plot which is something
that he's passionate about
and uh and it's gonna be like
a super nice thing for us moving forward
awesome i
also know that the team part of the
team's mission or information you had
shared with me
probably a year back was that you want
to hopefully be able to
like help other cities do something
similar and kind of
create maybe a working group among
other people using r in public sector
different data science teams and
i just wanted to open up the
conversation
about that if if anybody wants to to
jump in to really just see like what
would be the best way for us to all
start to do that and
be able to
network with each other and share
best practices
i think the meetups are great for being
able to like highlight different use
cases and ask questions
but i'm thinking like on a go going
forward basis
is that some kind of like slack channel
or a linkedin group
what would be helpful to you all or what
ideas do you have
yeah just to like before is anybody i
can't see if anybody's raising their
hands not yet
it it seems like like
some of that is
going on in linkedin groups now which i
i didn't think was
uh it didn't seem like like a viable
solution to me
some months ago but
a lot of things are moving in that
direction
i see manju just recommended that as
well
maybe we could start with testing that
out too and just for people who joined
this event as well and to invite other
people going forward
does anyone else have any other
ideas for how to do that or how to
better connect people
do i want that's a great point as well
there's also the um i find the slack
channels on the r for data science
online learning community really helpful
too
and so i will ask
john who moderates that if we could
create
a government
channel as well
yeah that'd be really really cool
and that's um if anybody's not in that
slack channel you can always just join
up by going and i'll put the
i'll put the link in the chat window but
it's just r4ds
dot io slash join
i see someone had unmuted if you have
anything else to add to
yes um i also have nice to meet you
thanks for your presentation today
and uh yeah cause i i'm kind of like old
school but i think i prefer also
face-to-face communication meeting
meeting the person who's working in that
field and have this experience asking
the question directly but it was kind of
our conference maybe we can have after
this cool video disappeared i'm not sure
it's gonna disappear but
after it gets better because one of the
things that you posted the art
conference which is pretty expensive and
yeah it's it's to me
ah should should it worth it or not
because some hundred dollars 100 so
i think
it's better for us to have some kind of
opportunity
meeting um people in the field and
sharing the opinions of it
definitely and hopefully we all will be
able to
meet at conferences again soon as well
but i do think a really good thing that
came out of the past two years as well
with these virtual events is that like
anybody can join and it's open to
everyone and
um free of cost obviously but if i can
never help
be like the middle person there
introducing people or
i'm also happy to do that
so i'm a professional community manager
here at our studio that's my new title
as of six months ago
so always feel free to reach out to me
directly to on linkedin or i'll put my
email in the chat
and i'd love to be able to help connect
people and maybe if that's a
like virtual coffee where we have like
smaller group chats as well to talk
about specific challenges that you're
facing or i don't know something
specific like shiny optimization um
happy to
to help set that up and organize it for
people too
um i know we got into all the questions
on slido and we are definitely way over
leonard so thank you so much for for
staying on and answering all the
questions i do want to just do one
last check to see if anybody else on has
anything that you want to ask or
things you'd like to see or feedback as
well be great to hear from you all
i just want to say thank you so much
leonard for an awesome presentation it's
so cool to
be able to dive deeper into that all
right
i just wanted to say
okay just if anybody wants to like talk
on linkedin or whatever like please add
me and i'll i'll you know answer any
questions and you know learn from you
and vice versa so thanks everyone
well thank you so much slinner have a
great rest of the day really appreciate
it and thank you all so much for joining
[Music]
you